honoring a hero the city of las vegas  council approved a street name  change to honor late metro lieutenant  eric lloyd  lieutenant lloyd died from covid  complications back in july of last year  now a portion of t.p lane will change to  eric lloyd street that street located in  the master plan community  sandstone between iron mountain road and  brent lane just over on the east of  u.s 95 family friends colleagues were  all a part of this very special moment  my family is very humbled for this  dedication  and we accept this on behalf of all of  our law enforcement our men and women  that fight and protect us on the streets  every day  and thank you to his squad that is here  this morning and to all his friends  that have known him for over 30 years  hearing there from lloyd's wife mindy  lloyd was an officer for three decades  he has served as a  president of the injured police officers  officers fund denise